Guys, my my lies are just like, haha, oops, haha, oops, oopsie,
oopsie, haha, oopsie. Unfortunately, because you've had to spur
about the footnote, right? They get to correct your your lies
about the footnote. So, now it's all going on the record. Literally
jumping off of a diving board directly onto a rake that smashes
him in the face.
Um, you guys are engaging with this trip to pound town guy in
chat on like the legal case. The legal case is not relevant.
Argue [music] the facts, the the bolted on facts, right? Okay.
All right.
Let's see if he's going to cover any of this. There's like him
reading the some of the docket entries.
Oh, this is his motion for sanctions.
>> I I maybe Listen, I kind of want to hear his thing cuz
I'm guessing he talks to his lawyers about it. I don't really
talk to lawyers about it, so I kind of want to hear what he's
gonna say. >> So, I'm trying to think of what >> Here
we are again. >> Sign of the economic times right there.
Sign of the economic times. That is >> I guess I'll just
talk.
>> So, we filed this u I think 3 or 4 days ago. This is
on the 1st of December. >> Oh, maybe we go through like
did Destiny do his stream on
on like uh the Discord and like how he was framing the cyber
stuff cuz I actually have not I'll be honest.
been a little crazy recently. Uh I've not been sleeping. I haven't
really looked at everything Cao posted in there and stuff. I'm
vaguely aware of what happened, but like I don't I can't actually
like litigate it very well. Does he do a stream going through
that? Maybe we check this out at some point. Time stamp could
have been a lot tighter. Don't worry about it. Checking out what
chat's saying. In her October 3rd, 2025 opposition opposition
to defendants pending motion to dismiss and for the sole purpose
of causing harm to defendant Steven K. on the second plaintiff
falsely asserted that he exchanged explicit material with a minor.
Specifically, plaintiff claimed to have identified Rose as censored
name. Some of this has to be redacted cuz some of this is under
seal. The purported recipient of the video Bunell allegedly transmitted
in April 2022 based on plaintiff's purported investigation. She
alleged that Miss Blank was a minor at the time. She supposedly
received the video and falsely concluded that Bunnell had exchanged
sex material with someone who was under the age of 18. So, if
you're if you weren't following this, they basically decided
to try to stick in a footnote in one of the filings. Um, oh,
you know, we hired a private investigator. That was a lie. They
just they lie everything, I guess, cuz that's okay. They just
went by what was posted on Kiwi Farms. Um, they lied and said
they had a private investigator. What? Why? Wait, how why is
he saying it's a lie?
I thought they knew who she was before. Am I crazy? I could have
sworn they knew who she was before
it was posted on KF. Am I crazy? >> And then they said
that uh and they decided to put in a footnote. This girl was
a minor, which has no bearing on her case whatsoever. Obviously,
>> wait, hold on. Okay, I would love if Destiny's watching
this, did he not tell
did his lawyers, just put it on the record, um, did he tell Pixie's
team who Rose was before the Kiwi Farms leaks? Did that happen?
Cuz I'd heard that in the background somewhere, but I've never
like I never gave any credence to it, but just I I kind of thought
that seemed more plausible to me, but maybe not.
He could clear that up. whatever they can to try to attack me.
Not only is Plaintiff's allegation knowingly and demonstrabably
false, but also the age of the purported recipient of the video
is irrelevant to plaintiff's claims and has no bearing whatsoever
on whether this court has subject matter jurisdiction here. So,
um they managed to well, not they, but somebody in um Justical's
Discord server threatened the uh victim and her family across
multiple email accounts. Can we just Can someone send me the
threats? Can I see the threats? I need to see the threats. I
I'm sorry. I actually need to see the threats here. Can I cuz
realistically if um if what he's saying I assume he's talking
about Cyba. If what he's saying is true and Cyber went and was
like, "You stupid [__] You need to you need to testify
in this case or else." If if that happened, I would I'd love
to see that cuz I Caba should probably be banned if that's the
case.
I We should We should actually lit litigate this right now. Um
in fact, do we have Destiny going over this somewhere? Do we
have like his actual video on this? Hold on.
>> Listen for another few seconds. Hold on. >> All
of Justical's Discord server knows this, so they laugh about
it. I think I've shown pictures of that. It's the I think the
SA dude, but basically harassed them and threatened the family
until they contacted Joan Peters in order to sit for a deposition.
Um, unfortunately, that depos
Okay. Did I mean, can I see that? Can I see the threats?
I I would just like to see the threats. Someone could send me
the threats. Hold on. Do I have to wait? Do I have to wait? I
have to. From what I seen, he was helping her scrub stuff from
the internet. Well, that's what I'd
I asked like I have people I trust. I'm like, "Hey, can you just
tell me as somebody who's like kind of outside of this, can you
just tell me you looked at Cyber stuff is was it bad
or something?" They're like, "No,
no. I think there's probably, sorry, Sy, but I hate to put I
hate to put you on like this, but there's probably a bit of a
red flag and if you're willing to contact people via like email
and stuff consistently,
um, that's probably a bit of a red flag. Now, without any further
behaviors there, without things like threats, I don't know if
it's like something I'd ban someone over. I'd just say like probably
you shouldn't do it. Probably shouldn't do it. But like it's
not morally wrong. It's just one of those things where I'm like,
well, if you're willing to reach out to creators or people you
know from online via their email like is cold emailing, like
that's probably a slight a bit of a red flag, but cold emails
in and of themselves are not like evil or morally wrong or threats
or even harassment.
Um, so yeah, was a train wreck for um the subhuman filth pixie
and her council. And what we find out during the deposition is
that this person never was in charge of any of the accounts that
they had ever been posted publicly online. So the Twitter account,
any Cash App account, the Discord account. >> Yeah, I thought
Cyber helped her get stuff taken down that was up and like possibly
doxing her,
but hey, whatever. I was talking to
was actually ran by another guy who
you should be able to understand how unbelievably everything
is related to this other dude. But
yeah, probably
sounds like that guy's got to get got after. Surely Destiny's
ready to go after that guy, right? That guy's like a sex trafficker.
Destiny has all of the unique information that they could use
to go after him. Surely he's doing that. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
Right. He's the person with all of the >> Um, so that comes
out in the um in the deposition. I think about
>> subhuman filth is pretty crazy. Didn't he say she should
sue him? Oh, yeah. I mean, he's obviously just lying. He He just
doesn't like where it's gone, right?
He just doesn't like where it's gone. How dare this stupid use
my exact tactics against me? How dare this
>> Halfway through the deposition, um, Pixie and Joan basically
just start accusing the girl of lying because that's all they
can do at this point because now they've lost completely on their
subject matter jurisdiction related to the video transfer date
for this person because the I mean they Okay, let's be real.
This is one. We all said no, no, no. It obviously is transmitted
in April. Come on. Come on.
[clears throat] Come on.
It was obviously April when the video was sent. Come on, man.
international trafficker dude is in um the UK. So that explains
the timestamps and then the fact that I've never had a conversation
apparently with this girl means that their footnote is also incorrect
which should have never been there in the first place. And so
obviously after the um deposition we made a request from them
like hey can you like can you file a correction on this cuz you
kind of were just like sticking this in public filings. Um, I
think they don't respond maybe for like a week. And then we said,
um, hey, um, why don't you,
uh, what do we, what do we say? Oh, we we basically said, if
you don't do this, we're going to file a rule 11 sanctions against
you. And then they said, well, if you file a rule 11 against
us, we're going to file a rule 11 against you.
And it's like, okay, you said one, at least two occasions. You
said on at least two occasions you had phone calls with her.
I thought I talked to this person on the phone, but I apparently
I didn't. I I know that some people you could get something wrong
from 2 or 3 years ago. I know that in the court of
guys I just listen I just got it wrong. I didn't like By the
way, I'll just say at this exact point in time he told me that
he went back and reviewed every single message he ever sent her.
Okay? So he's saying that oh I got it wrong but he never corrected
it. Right? And he went through every message he sent. You don't
think? Well, he went through every message he sent. He didn't
look and see. I think I corrected on him him on this in DMs.
I'd have to look it up after. I'm pretty sure I was like, "Oh,
Solo said you never talked to her." And he's like, "Oh, wait,
didn't I? Oh, maybe not." Oh, wait, didn't I? Didn't I got it
wrong twice with Pixie and Straight Raid. Very interesting. Very
cool. Very neat, guys. My My lies are just like, "Haha, oops.
Haha. Oops. Oopsie.
Oopsie.
Haha. Oopsie. justical discord server when uh do you notice he's
for like months now has to rant about the Discord instead of
me. I I'm almost a little bit sad that I feel like I have to
go back and start covering this stuff again because he will not
stop threatening to dox people in my Discord. He will not stop
threatening people in my Discord. He'll keep pressuring my community
until it breaks if I don't do anything. So he But it's a little
funny that he is having fights with like just random Discord
people, right?
Like that's that's what he's been doing now. Now he can actually
get mad at me again if he wants. We'll see. We will >> Opinion
in Kiwi Farms that if somebody says something at some point in
time, you can use one message to try to win an entire court case.
There's a reason why this case is dead. There's a reason why
when none of that is. >> It's not about the court case.
It's just saying you're a liar.
And he, by the way, all we use those messages for is to say he
was lying back here. Now he all he's done is gone. Well, I wasn't
lying. I was just wrong accidentally. It's like, okay. But like
the what we were arguing was that you were incorrect back then.
So you're just agreeing with us that we're right, right? Like
basically
Like when I pull up the messages to show, oh, he why did he apologize
for this? Why did he say he talked to her? It's to show that
he's unreliable. He's a very unreliable narrator, right? That
you can't trust his word. That you shouldn't trust his word.
He li he either lies or isn't concerned enough to get things
right most of the time.
Boom. He just he just said it. He's like, "Yeah, I am I am a
totally unreliable loser." Yeah, that's that's me. That's me.
And I know that it's fun online to try to have like one message
like, "Well, you said this one thing, so it must mean all blah
blah blah blah blah." But unfortunately, that's not how the big
boy world works. And you have to actually like,
>> by the way, we still don't care about the court case.
Like, I don't I don't care about how the court case turns out
at this point. It's literally just talking about who he is as
a person. That's what he doesn't like is because what's what's
happened is he wants to litigate this court case and use it to
go that's why I'm a good person that when I doxed this woman's
wife, when I've tried to dox multiple people who have done anything
at all related to this case, regardless of how good faith or
bad faith it is, when I go after everybody around this community,
when I lie about them, when I say they're related to like KF
or doers or something, when he when he does all of this, he's
like, "All of that was okay because I've been found not liable
in the Pixie case." Okay. No, that's not that's not the case.
You continually
yourself. You continually make yourself guilty again in the court
of public
by doing these totally deranged actions over and over again.
And you will never fix your reputation in the court of public
opinion while while acting this way. It just can't happen, right?
So, he's trying to he's hoping that if the court case gets dismissed,
we all go, "Oh, look, he was always he was always okay." No,
I don't care. I literally don't care about the outcome of the
court case at this point. I don't. And he he's also hoping that
the the court case will help him go, "Yeah, also all of the things
they said were wrong, but you've actually admitted to in filings
a ton of the things that were alleged against you."
Basically, the thing protecting him is, "Well, actually, yeah,
I am like a bad person. I have done all of these things. Yeah,
there are a whole bunch of like vaguely tied things that I've
also admitted to, like vaguely tied facts of the case that I've
also admitted to that make me look like a bad person, but
I technically only violated this consent
like 6 months before the law came into effect. So, good luck.
Good luck getting me. Good luck.
Yeah. No, unfortunately, I'm going to I'm we're all going to
be able to look at the case and say, "Oh, all these facts you
admitted to." Yeah, you're [__] up. You're [__]
up. Love seeing 23-year-old Adam Mockler regularly appearing
on CNN and taking infinitely more seriously than this Lawcal
loser. Oh, you say that, but Adam Mockler is actually going on
the America tour to help Destiny like reputation rehab, which
is very interesting to me. A guy with like a really bright future
who has a huge channel right now who's a big Destiny fan is going
to tie himself to
Interesting choice. Uh interesting choice at this point in time
specifically. I'm not going to get too much into the Adam Mockler
stuff, but it's it's just very neat. >> Build a case using
real evidence and not a single sentence or a single statement.
Keep in mind that at the time I'm talking to Pixie on this thing,
remembering my conversations with this girl uh or supposedly
the girl, but I guess it was just some creepy weirdo on this
account the entire time. I am standing in the shower uh getting
notified that 27 plus videos or whatever of me have been posted
online. Uh the majority of them are just single solo videos of
me. So, sorry if my memory recction wasn't absolutely flawless
or perfect at that particular point in time, but I I know that
you love the single messages.
>> No, I mean it's No, it's obvious what you did there.
It's not a single message. You also said it destroyed, but it's
not just a single message. There are multiple messages of you
admitting to things and and saying things that you've gone back
on and
dude,
he's just Wait, how far apart are the straight raid messages
and the pixie messages? Can I get those? Do we get those? I'm
going hook those up. Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. Oh,
I see. Destiny was doing some docs related stuff and he did it
on kick. That's why um took a while to find the the cyber stuff.
Okay, got it. Got it. Got it. Got it.
Okay. Well, I've now we've gone past it a little bit. I'll probably
wait to litigate this until >> cuz it's literally all you
people have. So, knock yourself out. Um the
>> oh like the he thinks the messages would be used in
like or are admissions that could be used in court. I like I
guess they're not but they are like it's clear that Pixie messages
him. He sees that like bad stuff's happened. He's trying to minimize
the fallout and what he does is he says, "Oh no, no, no. This
was like a close person to me. Of course I trusted this person."
Right? Let's Nobody's pointing out the fact that well he did
say yes. Okay. I had multiple voice calls. What he also said
was I've known this person for ye like I've known this person.
She's very closely trusted to me. I've talked to her multiple
times. Right? The the thought you were trying to invoke was also
an explicit lie cuz you are an explicit liar. Right? So, let's
say, okay, we're quibbling over. You said you talked to them
multiple times. You didn't talk to them. Maybe you thought you
remembered you did. You were implying that you could trust this
person with that material that that you never would have thought
they'd betray you, right? You'd known them for less than 10 days.
You'd known of this person for less than 10 days. That was a
total lie to try to make yourself seem more sympathetic or more
understandable to Pixie, but you were just completely lying about
it. So, it's not just about the calls. It's it's what you're
conveying at heart. What's what at the heart of that message
is I could trust this person. No, you couldn't. You're a record
is the record. Get [__]
As an initial matter, plaintiff and her council have been on
notice of the falsity of their allegations since at least October
23rd, 2025, the date of Miss uh the person's deposition at the
deposition. She testified to a bunch of things rather she also
testified a whole bunch of other things. Bonnel did not share
any material with um this is the Rose account or the Rose person,
the underlying person or any other minor. In light of this testimony,
Bunnel demanded the plaintiff file a notice of erata and corrected
opposition without the false and defamatory allegation included
therein. Despite this demand, plaintiff and her council have
failed and or refused to do so in violation of their obligations
under rule 11. The court should impose appropriate sanctions.
I think rule 11 just has to do with like filing things that um
I think rule 11 just has to do with um like making sure the stuff
that you file with the court is truthful. Justin, you said they
were fairly close to you to Pixie, too, because this was a person
who I thought was fairly close. had a I'd had two or three years
of conversations with this person. Yes.
Yeah. So,
he just he just li he reality didn't matter, right? That's who
Destiny is at his core. There's so much there. He wants to say
it doesn't matter. His immediate reaction to somebody being upset
with him is to say the thing that will make them less upset with
him regardless of how true it is. He doesn't care about the truth.
That's not what's on his mind right there. His reaction is to
lie to minimize the damage to him as much as possible. Automatic,
right?
10 days. Somebody Oh, hopefully somebody in DG chat asked how
long he'd known Rose for when he sent the Pixie video. Maybe
we get some acknowledgement of that, too. >> Factual background.
>> Thought he was a truth seeeking machine. No, humans
aren't truth seeeking machines. Why did you make these? >> On
September 19th, 2025, final file a motion to dismiss the operative
complaint on the grounds that the court lacked subject matter
jurisdiction over this dispute because the date of the alleged
transmission of the video preceded the effective date of the
federal statute which forms the basis of the plaintiff's complaint.
Pixie knew this from the very beginning as well. Um maybe more
will come out about this, maybe not, but basically um I can say
with 100% certainty that Pixie and Lauren have been collaborating
to hide and obscure evidence when I keep complaining publicly
and I keep saying they're not giving me discovery. She's not
giving me discovery. She's not giving me discovery. Um, that's
and I'm lying to you. I know why they're not giving me discovery.
It's because the both of them have collaborated on destroying
stuff so that they have nothing to turn over to me. That's what
I really meant when I was saying that. But that that's what's
been going on the entire Okay. So, give us your evidence of that.
Can you give us like literally just So, he's saying I'm 100%
certain that that they're destroying evidence. So, I know they're
I I think they're colluding because I'm 100% certain they're
destroying evidence. Okay. Show me the evidence that they're
destroying things. Yeah, I understand. Some people just let the
things this guy says go and they're just like, "Oh, that's true.
That's true now." But it's not. Show any evidence at all. What
is the evidence you have? Hello. I Bro, what is happening? How
god this is actually the actual reason why I don't like covering
this stuff as much anymore is because just seeing like this community
like hear that and then they actually don't process or ask any
questions. there. Nobody hears that and goes, "Oh, I need Could
you show me some evidence of that?" Nobody. Not a single person.
Not a single person time. Um, that's why I said I'm going after
Lauren's legal license as soon as this case is over. Um, I'm
going to be filing the trying to file the mother of all bar complaints
in Florida to get her disbarred. Um, and then Pixie, if she ever
tries to do character and fitness or whatever for whatever, you
know, dog ass law school she's going to, it'll be the same thing.
>> Okay. So, now he's threatening them. Does this guy remember
when he was like, "Oh, you should file a legal case. She should
just file a legal case. She should just sue me."
Did he not say that,
[laughter]
Ah, God. It's crazy. It's crazy watching this. On October 3rd,
plaintiff filed an >> That's got to be Is that not just
like a total
That's got to be some kind of violation. No. Is that not like
a
of of like somebody suing you for like a crime? You're like,
"After this, I'm going after her in the like I'm going after
her in character and fitness."
Like, you could want to do that. And maybe, hey, let's say hypothetically
he has all the evidence he says and doesn't want to share it
on the internet. And he's this time telling the truth in a way
that's totally disconnected from how he normally lies. Let's
say, let's give him the the most charity you could possibly give
him for no reason. Let's give him that. Shouldn't he still not
say that? Isn't that still a really stupid [__] thing
to say? Like in terms of legality,
shouldn't that be like super not good to say? I But hey, man,
he's the guy who actually understands the legal system and stuff.
Remember when Pixie's lawyers were going to get sanctioned for
what was it for? I can't even remember what he originally said
they're going to get sanctioned and disbarred for. It's been
a long time >> to the motion the opposition in the opposition.
Uh plaintiff falsely asserted the bal exchange sex supposed to
be with the minor specifically in a wholly irrelevant footnote.
plaintiff falsely stated. After finally ascertaining Rose's legal
identity, plaintiff has obtained evidence that Rose's date of
birth is October 30th, 2004. Thus, when Bono was exchanging content
with Rose between March of 2022 and until October 30th of 2022,
Rose was a minor. Um, referencing the footnote that they put
in this filing,
the supporter basis claim plaintiff identified blank as the
uh finally astrating. I guess I could have gone through now that
I'm thinking about it with Carlos's thing with the the other
rule 11 sanction. I probably should have gone through and looked
at how Destiny said talked about exchanging
>> individual referred to in her pleadings as Rose and
to demonstrate that Miss Blank was a minor at the time of events
alleged. Plaintiff filed a copy of Miss Blank's official certification
of Department of Motor Vehicles driving record exhibit B to the
opposition. On October 23rd, uh plaintiff deposed Rose in Rockford,
Illinois. At her deposition, Rose testified to a bunch of things.
Um, basically this is more or less is
who applied for like the seal for this cuz I I'm just curious
who who applied for the seal like to put this under seal and
redact it cuz we all know whatever is being said here. Andrew
Breler does not mind pushing what's allowed to be put into into
like any of these filings.
I just I feel like what's being said here is probably some goofy.
So [__] that he knows doesn't exculpate him at all.
Okay.
Well, who knows? We'll see. It was Joan. No, maybe it does escalate
him. If it if it's under seal from Joan, maybe does excate him.
Or is this just the general Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, hold on, wait. This might Hold on. I might
be This might be the thing they jointly agreed to. Did they They
jointly agreed to one thing, which was uh for witnesses to have.
It was like for discovery or something, right? Um protective
order gring discovery, I think. Did they both agree to that?
I think they might have both agreed to that now that I think
>> that I've never communicated with this person ever in
my entire life, which is which was a mind to me. But do lawyers
not realize how like absolutely unhinged and unprofessional they
look? To be honest, I'm surprised the judge like I correct me
if I'm wrong. Okay. The what appears to have happened here is
the relationship they had was sort of like Eboyfriend, Egirlfriend.
Okay. Eboyfriend, Egirlfriend.
and he managed her like social media while she shot videos and
stuff. Now it's like really bad. Is there proof that he did this
with other people? Maybe he did this with like a whole bunch
of people and he was like a totally Maybe he's like a 30-year-old
who's Maybe it's like Andrew Tate digital Discord Andrew Tate.
Maybe. But if he was doing this with with like his partner, okay,
I it's not all the things he's building it up to be. That person
would be bad. It would be obviously bad to take your partner
who's a minor and get them to and then you distribute that. It's
obviously bad. Okay. Distri distribution obviously bad. But what
I would also say is he's trying to make it seem like she was
like the uh
uh like
he had no way of knowing this was happening and like this was
done to like ruin his life. I think what was probably happening
was they just knew that this guy would pay them a bunch of money
like he would just be like a pay kind of thing or maybe they
like the content. they like built that relationship that way.
Like it's not I don't think it's necess like I have
maybe it is the case that it's the pimp. I just haven't seen
any evidence to that yet. And I don't know. I don't know how
personally invested a pimp would be. Hasn't come out yet and
said like you guys need it. Who knows? We'll see when the rulings
come out. I mean, there's still a non-zero chance. I just wanted
the motion to dismiss. But um they don't care about looking unhansed
or not. This is a purely one trillion%. Just look at whatever
people say about me and know that it's probably just about them.
This is just a spiked driven endeavor where Pixie and Lauren
are doing everything they can to cover for an actual
child producing uh
trafficker because and you Destiny understands that he's the
John here, right? He's the customer. He is the buyer. He is the
>> He understands that, right? Does he I listen I've never
paid for on the internet. Luckily, I I'm pretty sure
I I think so. Listen, I've been on the internet a long time.
I I'm like 99% sure I've never paid for anything on the internet.
So like I can say I've never paid for I've never like gotten
from someone. I don't do that. I don't use like random Discord
people for this, right? I don't try to mine my fan base for contacts.
It's not the way it works, man.
Um
it's so goofy.
Like he he somehow escapes doing any due diligence here, too,
right? Like we're still ignoring the fact I I want to see this
come out. Like I hope this gets subpoenaed that Desi did no due
diligence on this at all. Right. Like he ostensibly I've not
seen him dispute those Twitter DMs that got leaked which were
something along the lines of like, "Hey, you seem young. Could
I get some pictures?" And then he got can I get some ID? And
then he got basically nothing. And then he moved forward, right?
That's like what he did. He was like, "Hey, can I get some ID
here?"
And she was like, "Oh, I can show it's really me." And he's like,
"Sounds good, man. Let's rock and roll cuz they just want to
keep hitting my reputation. That's the only thing this is at
this point. But um yeah,
but your reputation is like something that should be hit. Dispute.
He's not disputing the facts, right? Like he's basically saying
these people keep wanting to put the truth out because it hurts
me. These people keep exposing the truth because it hurts me
over and over and over again. They keep producing true facts
about me
and it keeps hurting me. Somehow we've created this idea that
that doing that is like automatically just evil, right?
Exposing the truth about somebody that is like basically showing
them to be a predatory like
emotionally
predatory emotional void of a human being. It's like no that's
fine. That could be put out there. I don't know if Destiny knows
this, like this is basically the same level of wrong as him exposing
like the misk stuff, hosting those calls, right? Putting other
people's personal life out there. He just doesn't like that it's
happening to him. He totally loved when he was reaping, but now
that he's or so when he was sewing, but now that he's reaping,
he's got a problem.
I'm sorry. These are just true facts that are coming out about
you. That's it. Bunell did not share any content with Miss Blank
or any other minor. Plaintiff and her attorneys know this now.
On October 30th, 2025, council with Bonell sent a letter to plaintiffs
council demanding the plaintiff file a notice of arata and corrected
pleading to retract plaintiff's knowingly false allegation in
her opposition. To date, plaintiff's council has not provided
a substantive response to the letter, nor have they taken the
corrective action requested. Rule 11 of the federal rules of
civil procedure provides impertinent part by blah blah blah.
So let's just you can't lie in your here plaintiff's false allegation
that bal exchange material with a minor was included for an improper
purpose, namely to publicly humiliate and harass Balance with
the court's opinion of him. critically the age of the purported
recipient of the victim or I'm sorry of the video has no bearing
whatsoever on plaintiff's claim of this action nor does it have
any bearing on whether the court has subject matter jurisdiction
in this case which is the threshold issue subjudice judice judicy
moreover has been not false violations at least 23rd 25 they
have failed and or refused to correct normally false contention
the opposition council for refusal to prep and intentionally
inflammatory misstatement warrants world 11 sanctions would you
prefer not to win on the motion to dismiss so you can get subpoena
info from Lauren for her disar no there's I'm never getting anything
via subpoena from Lauren her and pixie have been maliciously
and intentionally covering their trail and doing stuff to make
sure that nothing will ever be produced from her that will be
incriminating. They Oh, example example. Can we can we get some
proof of this? Is there any proof of this? This has been in play
since the very start of these proceedings. So, it doesn't matter
if anything happens courtwise or any of that. It literally doesn't
matter. Um, yeah.
Do you notice the the levels that everybody operates at?
By the way, given that rationale, you now have to admit that
Desty's automatically guilty by deleting all of his logs. Okay,
Desty's automatically guilty of sending this video cuz he deleted
all of the logs, right? He just did the same thing, dude. What?
For the reason stated here in Bono respectfully requests of the
court saying, >> um, actually, I'll never have any evidence
of except we have reason to believe. So, I've seen nothing that
indicates that Lauren's done something in this case that's like
evil, right? But we have every reason to believe Destiny would
send that video and then delete evidence of it. Send that video
and lie about it. There is a lot of other evidence, a lot of
other adjacent evidence around this that leads us to believe
that that could be the case. I have yet to see a single tangible
factual thing except the ellipses on Kiwi Farms and Reddit that
leads me to believe that would lead me to believe anything Desty
says is related to Lauren. Okay.
Ancient plaintiff and her council jointly and severally severally
severely severally. This is a legal this is a legal term
rule 11 including element to um monetization push that okay
um is a declaration from my lawyer. Um
this is a transcript from the deposition. This is under seal
until I don't know if this technically ever gets on sale or not.
I don't know. >> I sure hope it does. I I sure hope that
transcript ends up on the internet.
Okay, I understand that that's going to be like
I ah
eventually or something with redacted personal information. I
just want to know what what she testified to actually happening.
Okay. I just want the truth. I just want the truth. This is our
email that we sent to them saying, "Hey, you should correct this
because this is not true. This was sent on October 30th." Oh,
you have to give them a notice before you file a um rule 11 um
I think of 3 weeks. You have to give them a notice before you
file like anything. Or maybe that that's an extra rule, but the
judge asked them, "Hey, could you like before you file motions
in my court so you don't spam the docket, can you guys talk before
you file motions? You need to actually uh like meet up." I forget
what the word is. There's a word. Oh, meet and confer. Do a meet
and confer. before you can file it. I don't even know if they
responded to this other than to say that they were going to file
a rule 11 against us if we file rule 11 against them, which I
don't even think you can do. I I don't know if that's
did he not read that they responded with
he must have prepared for this, right? He must have understood
that they we know Destiny loves to
in a few weeks. I think they just said that if we file one, they'll
fight one. That was it. So, um I'll get to Jones Motion soon.
Um I've got a lot of stuff to post about this guy later as well.
So, esports Batman is one of the only fake lawyers left in just
Discord
>> Oh, because he's So, this is him making good on a sorry,
saying he wants to make good on a threat to dox somebody. So,
when he says that, I've got stuff I want to post on this guy
later. He is on YouTube saying that he wants to dox people. He's
threatening to dox people. Um, he'll not do this on YouTube because
he doesn't want to lose his channel. But, I'm just saying that's
what he's doing here when he says that. You caught that, right?
>> I got a lot of stuff to post about this guy later as
well. So, he's >> got a lot of stuff to post about this
guy later. He's going to dox somebody who appeared on his stream
for years, who was like a main character on his stream for years.
Well, a side character, right?
He just wants to keep doxing people. Do he post stuff about him?
Uh, he hasn't yet, but he's followed through on most of the threats
to dox people. So, he just keeps threatening to dox people over
and over and over again. Isn't Destiny still demonetized? I think
he's 6 months until he can um what do you call it? He can >> Sportsman
is one of the only.
So, well, according to Rose, who knows what the actual truth
is.
Uh, okay. But I thought she was impersonated. How does she know
exactly what happened if someone was acting as her? I'm not saying
she's lying. Just she can't know everything if someone is impersonating
her. You can't have someone testify to personal knowledge if
they weren't there/ involved with the event.
Okay, so that's 100% correct. She was involved obviously, right?
He said he can reapply in two weeks today. Okay.
Isn't Destiny still getting KCIP? Yeah, but I'm not going after
his case. Yeah, I I Dude, Kick isn't going to do I don't think
so.
so this was just correct. Uh, he was wrong in that he thought
she wasn't being impersonated, but it's correct as in you can't
have someone testify to personal knowledge if they weren't there/
involved with the event. As in there'd be no point in having
this person testify, right? But they were involved. They were
absolutely involved. They got forwarded a bunch of the videos.
No, no, no. When you multiream, you just get less money. But
also, I think he just multistreamed anyway and got money. You
weren't supposed to, but I think he just did. Anyway, um yeah,
I So, this is I Is this why he's doxing people?
What? What? What is wrong with this? Can somebody What is he
even mad about here?
Fake lawyers left and just kills Discord server that likes to
poke holes in this. I just want to say that a few weeks ago,
I laughed about the fact that people are like, "How could any
of this possibly be true? Like, it seems so unbelievable." Um,
true. Thank you. I agree. It does seem really unbelievable, which
is one of the reasons why it was such a Okay, that's because
you the way you doxed Rose was you posted the picture of her
with her full face visible so she could be reverse image searched
and you did it in her wearing a DG shirt and nothing else implying
she was sending a DG shirt picture to somebody in a like manner,
somebody she had some sort of relationship with, right? You don't
just send like the t-shirt only picture to some dude you think
is like a friend or to just somebody who's unrelated, right?
Oh, he also doctor college. Yeah, he also does college and her
major. But I'm saying that when he did that, that raised some
questions of like, wait, how did she become a DJ? Why was she
a Destiny fan? Why did she have this shirt on if she wasn't involved
at all? Like, this this seems really weird that it was a worker
who was a Destiny fan but didn't know that her material was being
used to catfish Destiny. That seems totally unbelievable. And
it turns out it was totally unbelievable,
right? Just completely unbelievable.
Um, so like Joan Peters and Pixie, they have switched gears into
saying that, "Oh, well the other girl must just be lying about
everything." Um, because there's no way that any of that can
be true. If that's the road that you want to go down, uh, then
feel free to do whatever you want. Remember, no matter what happens,
I have to be the devil. Literally every horrible thing.
No. And by the way, the thing the thing I went or the thing I've
been going on a lot isn't the fact that he this person, right?
It's the fact that he retained child abuse materials for months
after being informed they were child abuse materials. That was
my problem, right?
That's That's been the problem. Hey, you retained child. Hey,
Willie Mack was right about you. Hey, Willie Mack did really
need to call the cops on you. You're a psycho. You got told that
this person was underage and you're a psycho and you retained
that that and that doesn't go away with a middleman. This while
you could you could do some some shucking and jiving in terms
of legal responsibility maybe with this or in terms of what evidence
can be presented maybe with this. You can't really shuck and
jive on whether or not you your material was sent, whether or
not you were like basically sending through an intermediary to
a minor and receiving through an intermediary from a minor. You
can't shuck and jive on that. You can't shuck and jive on
on her being like aware of this. She's got the shirt and >> it's
over.
>> Like it it doesn't matter if there was a middleman.
That middleman doesn't change anything. Um yeah, it doesn't even
change really technically in terms of the messaging. I have like
it changes nothing in terms of the messaging either because you
had concerns about age. Yes. Right. You had concerns about her
age. You asked about it or at least that's what the messages
say. I haven't seen him deny that yet. Maybe not. Maybe that's
not real. But I think he even said he asked for like a college
ID or something. Right. And
and you didn't actually get those concerns assuaged and then
you started receiving material and sending her material. So you
you had some concerns about the age. You let them go by the
>> I don't know. with me and otherwise that they must be
lying. Um,
>> but I thought she was impersonated. How does she know
exactly what happened if someone else was acting as her? I'm
not saying she's lying, just she can't know everything if someone
is impersonating her. You can't have someone testify to personal
knowledge if they weren't there/ involved with the event. So
the the person who was operating the account who was catfishing
me with her stuff. So this is a common thing that these bring
like, "Oh, well then how did you get how tell me Destiny how
is it that she's wearing your brush?" Haha. Because this guy
ordered it, sent it to her house, had her take pictures of it,
and then Oh, god.
Is he real right now?
So, he knows who Solo is. So, he just knows who he just knows
who Solo is. Uh-huh. So, like this person was running an Only
Fans account, and like most Only Fans accounts, she was getting
somebody else to manage the um to manage like the backend chatting
stuff, the the DMs directly, right? And Desi's like, "Yes, I
was paying for this minor only fans." Not an only fans. She wasn't
on Only Fans, but I'm saying it would be the same thing as going,
"Yeah, I'm paying for Only Fans, but it's okay because, you know,
some 30-year-old Indian was receiving my DMs." Brother,
brother, I don't I really don't understand. I think his identity
was released in the deposition. Okay, maybe maybe he says that
later, but I'm saying from the merch stuff. We were asking that
months ago, right, before the deposition happened. Hey, how'd
she get that shirt, bro? Hey, bro. Bro, how'd she get that shirt?
How'd she get that shirt? and then posted those pictures of her
in my merchandise to me on the catfish account. This person went
way the beyond to try to and catfish me and make me like to ensure
that I really thought this person was who I was talking to. So
yes, if you think it's incredibly crazy and unlikely and weird
and whatever, yes, welcome to my life. Nobody's asking did Destiny
send this person money? That would be my real question was like
what did they think they were getting out of this is my concern.
I actually don't know. Maybe they were just fans. Maybe they
just watch stuff in these communities. I think they did. But
like I actually do wonder
what they got out of this. Like was he sending the money? I don't
know.
Calling it catfishing sounds weird. Yeah, it's like it's like
some weird fetish. I literally don't know how to talk about it.
It's like it is weird what's happening here because she is
like providing the material. She's literally fully like okay
with with this person being with her material. She just isn't
participating in the conversation directly. It's like I don't
know. But you also could just accuse, you know, the actual victim
of all this uh as just somebody who's lying over and over again
with absolutely no evidence. But um
Uh I also I just said I By the way, I didn't say she was lying
for sure. I what I said was
I think she would be incentivized to lie, but I don't know. It
might be that Solo was there. Even if that is the case, blah
blah blah about Solo. I just handled both realities. You know
what I'm saying? >> Um anyway, that was our filing on December
1st. I think Destiny is now trying to say they were all out to
get him from the start. like they should make a movie out of
this. I think that's what he's trying to imply with the solo
person is that like this was meant to like ruin his life in some
way like from the very beginning. And I don't know if that's
the case.
Yeah, I really don't. We have three new filings from plaintiff
filed today. Oh boy. Did he order it from your store? Wouldn't
you have his payment details then? Um Oh.
Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Wait, what? Wait. Huh?
Uh-oh. What is he what is he saying to
>> yeah, I I would
>> The issue is that all of my legal work >> The
issue is that all of my legal work?
Wait, what's Bro, you literally doxed Rose. You literally doxed
Rose. You literally doxed Rose. You literally doxed Rose. You
literally doxed Rose. You literally doxed Rose. What? Why are
you keeping this guy's identity secret? What details then? Yeah,
I I would. The the issue is that all of my legal work initially
was going to be plaintiff work. Also, ignore everything I'm saying
because apparently I'm lying about all of this despite the fact
that multiple people have seen this packet that I was putting
together, but everybody says I'm lying about this on server because
that's fine cuz these people are all subhuman. I think probably
you're just lying about like how serious you were about doing
it. If it was like a serious thing you thought you had to pursue,
then you would pursue it either way, right? But you've actually
made Pixie your like number one enemy instead.
You don't really feel all that wronged by this guy because you
don't really care about your nudes being out there.
Or you'd go after him, right? Isn't he the person who did the
most harm? Holy, he's obsessed with us. I Well, dude, I The funny
thing is is most people a lot of people in the kick chat don't
even talk in the Discord,
right? Like they're very disconnected communities in a lot of
ways. A lot of people in the Kickhat don't talk in the Discord.
And like the Discord people, it's like a fairly calm conversation
most of the time. Honestly, now it's getting to be like one-sided
again. Kind of sucks, right? Because he threatened to dox all
the people who were in the channel. Anybody who engaged in the
channel, he threatened to dox all of them. So, a lot of the reasonable
people on the other side that we'd have like reasonable conversations
with about what the legal case was meaning and stuff, they left
cuz Destiny is threatening to dox anybody who participates over
and over again. It's sad. But the initial firm that I was working
for in uh New York was going to be plaintiff work to go against
the person who leaked everything. As soon as the defense work
started, the plaintiff case took a back not a backseat. I just
I asked it because I can't vote for psychologically or monetarily
to run two huge lawsuits at the same time.
Okay. Wait,
I thought Why would you have to run it? I thought you were going
to hand it over to the FBI.
I thought wasn't that his plan? I thought he said he was going
to take it to the FBI. Am I Am I wrong on that? Wouldn't he be
like you you like create the packet and then hand it off to the
FBI? Wait, what?
I have nothing to give the police. I couldn't possibly give anything
to the police.
Bro, how does this how does he flip-flop like this over and over
and over and over and over again? He he literally has no idea
which way is up. He is drowning.
Okay, so theoretically the payment information would be available
um from the person who initially the merch was sold to. That
was a road that I was going down. But in order to get the information
from them, their legal team won't release it to me because it
includes addresses and everything else without um without a subpoena.
And since I didn't file that lawsuit yet for the New York case
because we weren't ready to file that lawsuit yet, um I didn't
have anything there that I could use to to do legal pressure
against them. Um so I thought it was a packet you were taking.
Weren't you taking a packet to the FBI? Destiny be like, uh Pixie
is really mean, so I'm going to let this international child
trafficker go. I'm just going to let that guy walk. Yes, I am
the only person with information on him. I am the only person
who could go find this information, but I'm going to let him
walk cuz Pixie's mean. Cuz Pixie cost me a lot of money.
And somehow he'll paint my community as the ones who want to
let the solo guy off the hook. Are you out of your mind? Objectively,
he is the only person who has access who can do this. He is the
only one. But Pixie was really mean. Actually, Pixie was really
super mean. And and that's up. And now that child, that child
trafficker has to be allowed to go free. We can't go after him.
Yeah, I know I'm the only one with any information here, but
listen, I can't go to the FBI, dude. I can't psychologically
handle going to the FBI now. Could you imagine,
dude? What? Huh? Dude.
Uh,
it's absolutely crazy. >> So, yeah. All right. Number one,
>> dude. I have to go back. I have to go back and like
look did anybody ask but in order to get the information from
them their legal team won't release it to me because it includes
addresses and everything else without um without >> so
we needed some legal authority some subpoena some civil suit
that we could use the court to go after to get this stuff this
information released right we we need that uh but I can't do
that cuz Pixie sued me so
how how how
sorry it's because it's a cult because it's a cult. Just chill.
It's because it's a cult.
Uh, actually, all these justical Discord people really want to
just let this child trafficker off the hook. They want to let
him go. They don't They won't do anything to go after him cuz
they don't care. Hey, Destiny, could you like file that subpoena?
Get that guy's information so you could actually go after him
so the police could see it. So, anyone could see it. Um, Pixie
is really mean. I can't psychologically handle that right now.
Yeah, we did put the whole packet together, but I can't handle
it. Are you serious?
Are Are you serious? Right.
[laughter] Okay. Okay. All right. We have no information to go
on to try to find the solo person. Destiny does. He said as much
repeatedly.
yeah. No, no doubt. Hey, Destiny, I have a I have a trade offer
for you. I'm going to say we'll we'll do a fundraiser for you.
Might might be kind of mediocre. All right. to help you fund
putting this packet together. Okay, but just dox solo instead
of esports Batman and Supreme. You can let Supreme and esports
Batman go. You don't have to dox them. Just dox solo instead.
Awesome trade deal. Unbeatable. Maybe the best deal in the history.
The best trade deal in the history of trade deals. Okay. Doc
Solo instead of esports Batman. Doc Solo. The international child
trafficker. The the child predator. the child's predator. Okay,
dox him and do not dox Wicked Supreme, your former friend or
esports Batman, longtime contributor to your streaming community.
Maybe. Hey, h how about it, man? How about it? Could we maybe
go with that? I'm just That seems like it could be cool. A subpoena.
And since I didn't file that lawsuit yet for the New York case,
because we weren't ready to file that lawsuit yet, um I didn't
have anything there that I could use to to do legal pressure
against them. Um so, >> Wait, wait, wait. What are we supposed
to believe? They upped their games. the last time they tried
to last time they tried to actually go after him. Dude,
>> all right. Number one, plaintiff Jane Doe's motion to
modify the scheduling
>> Is there a reason you don't just blacklist Jizman server?
I understand you like on them in chat, etc., but usually you
just harsh ignore these types of human trash, not publicly on
them. Oh, the reason he does this is because he needs to create
a villain for his case. Oh, cakes back. That's sad. That's very
sad to me.
Um, I wonder what he tells these people behind the scenes. is
very sad. Oh well, oh well. Oh well. Oh well. Bl of Jane do buying
through the out council and pursuing to federal rules blah blah
blah hereby moves the day from finding the scheduling order.
So this is her begging to um kick back discovery despite the
fact that they've found nothing, produced nothing and done nothing
so far and have operated in the most bad faith manner possible.
Um including but not limiting to fabricating a person like Abby
who is clearly like mentally ill or has brain injury to get a
statement from her and then refused to produce her for any deposition.
Have not sat her for deposition at all. They've got no statements,
no evidence, nothing from her. They simply got a piece of paper
to the night before our evidentiary hearing and then off into
the wind she disappears despite the fact that initially they
said they fully represented her and then apparently they changed
their mind on that and then they said they represented her for
matters [music] of the subpoena and then they changed their mind
on being able to provide us information about that. So they literally
>> Wait, when did they say they represent her for the purpose
of accepting service? I thought they didn't say that.
any of these people. Oh, see that that
to me says two things. One is that uh probably that is happening.
I wouldn't I wouldn't doubt that they just told Abby like don't
bother responding to anything cuz they're just going to like
harass you more. I wouldn't doubt that and that's kind of [__]
up for Destiny. I
Kate couldn't pass a technical interview. [__] at
le code. Uh, no. You're totally wrong. You're completely out
of your mind. Kake is an incredible engineer. Shut the [__]
up. >> Uh, shut up. >> People for deposition. Why
they couldn't have filed anything earlier from Molina or anybody
else. Um, but because they've dragged their feet on everything
because it's not even they dragged their feet on everything.
They just have nothing. And they know they have nothing. And
they know that. >> How do you know that? Cuz I've had technical
conversations with the guy
>> That's how I know. >> Come up. >> But now
they want to move back. Um, Discovery was supposed to end in
2 weeks. Um, this is Do you know who Solo is now? I know everything
now. Um, but but it doesn't matter. Oh, right. It was uh is up
for Destiny. Maybe that they told her to go off into the wind.
But also, it tells me that he doesn't think it's getting dismissed
so long as the they can't depose her and like make her crack
under the pressure and say she's like lying about something or
something along those lines, right? You know what I'm saying?
Like I think probably cake does not pay people to do it for him.
Shut up. Although he maybe he does now or something. I have no
idea. But
cake's smart.
Um, Chader's pretty smart, too.
Wait. Yeah, we have to go back to Does he Did he just say he
knows everything now? So, I think there's probably good reason
to think that um
Man, there's there's probably good reason to think that this
is going to stay alive, right? It's going to survive the the
dismissal with the Abby stuff there. That that makes it survive
subject matter jurisdiction uh dismissal. That That's what that
little spur tells me. >> Now, they want to move back. Um,
Discovery was supposed to end in 2 weeks. Um, this is Do you
know who Solo is now? I know everything now. Um, but but it doesn't
matter until this court case is over. Um, so Discovery is supposed
to end on December 16th. This is supposed to be the thing that
I was like petrified and terrified of because apparently I was
hiding so much stuff. But alas, it has been plaintiff who has
been engaged in a rampant um
deletion of and obscuring of and hiding of materials while she
continues to send me a whole bunch of irrelevant random stupid
while she visits her fake wife um that she has in Miami that
she illegally married to get a green card. Um I know for a fact
that this is exactly what she did because Lauren de Laguna also
helped facilitate this. All of this is 100% true. She could sue
me if she doesn't like it. Um because truth is an absolute defense
to defamation and I know how
Um, Destiny, we have we haven't even reached critical mass yet.
We There are still people out there who have viable claims against
Destiny under Cardi that are within the statute deadline that
can be pursued and should be pursued and I hope they do get pursued
and they are not public at all yet. Okay.
Now, Destiny, go ahead and tell me. Go ahead and sue me if that's
wrong because truth is an absolute defense against defamation.
Okay. So, Cardi is the statute. It's the civil action regarding
distribution of intimate images. Two eyes Cardi. Okay. There
there are Well, no, hold on. I'm actually telling the truth to
Kill Sunset. You could say this and say like, "Sue me." Obviously,
when somebody has the resources to sue you, that's probably not
smart, right? To say, "Okay, I'm I'm I'm explicitly saying I'm
not defaming you. I know this is true, right?" But I do know
this is true. He has the money to sue me. He's He knows Lauren
doesn't have the money to sue him, but he knows he has the money
to sue me. He could totally go after me. Tisha is so knock yourself
out. Like I said, this is all stuff I'm going to be going on
hardcore after this case ends. Which is probably one of the reasons
why they wanted to delay it ending. But uh more specifically,
plaintiff respectfully request an extension of the [snorts] What's
the relevance? Why did he bring that up? Um yeah, I don't know.
I think he's saying that Pixie and Lauren de Lagona are colluding
in some way and he knows this for 100% fact, but the facts have
been deleted or sorry they that they've deleted evidence of them
colluding and now yeah I but he knows this for 100% fact but
he also doesn't show the evidence of why he knows it for 100
like
And I know that he says this about my server. He says stuff like
this about my server with no evidence when it's false. So I I
don't I I have a strong feeling that he's just lying here, but
discovery cut off of 60 days, which would place the new discovery
cutoff date on February 17th, 2026
with a proposed new deadline for dispositive motions of March
16th, 2026, and a pre-trial pre-trial motions deadline of April
18th, 2026 with the current trial date of May 18th, 2026 remaining
in place unless the court finds a brief continuence of the trial
date to be appropriate. Um there is no world where uh this if
if this got extended the discovery all the way to February. I
don't believe that that the trial date would remain the same.
They're going to try to kick it all down the road as much as
possible. The active discovery period in this matter did not
commence until the protective order governing discoveries issued
blah blah blah. This leaves no more than 3.5 months for the parties
to conduct discovery under the current scheduling order. As of
today and further detailed below, the following discovery has
not yet been completed. One written discovery has been exchanged
but there are unresolved objections to defendants defendants
document production. I have produced way more than she has and
I produce everything that's responsive to what she's asking for.
The only stuff that they're still asking for is like like we
need like like Lyan's address or we need um cryptographic hashes.
Like if you want I could just go generate a hash on all my text
files. It's just most random in the universe. But there's like
seven or eight outstanding things that Nice. Sorry. There's like
seven or eight outstanding things that we've requested that we
have nothing of. I don't have any of Pixie's conversations with
Aaron. I don't have any of her conversations with Lauren. I don't
have any conversations that are super responsive to any like
all of the people that we've found for >> Wait, why is
the conversation with Lauren relevant?
Has he has he given like just going into So he as he argues that
everything's irrelevant to his case all the time, right? Why
is the Lauren Why is the Lauren thing that's based on your like
total totally schizophrenic theory relevant? Why would anything
with Lauren de Laguna be relevant?
Lauren de Lagon is not part of the case. This is like his favorite
thing to say is he's Lauren De Lagoon is not part of the case.
He was just saying she's not a witness to anything. She's not
She shouldn't be talking about anything while deposing her while
Andrew Breler's calling her a witness in documentation.
Everybody I want to talk to is very involved and they're not
providing anything. And everybody who wants to talk to me or
talk to somebody around me or talk to somebody about me, that's
they're all irrelevant. All of it's totally irrelevant to the
case. Come on, man. For subpoenaing people that we've had to
find on our own. She didn't disclose any of them initially and
they've tried to throw up roadblocks to us subpoenaing or um
um doing depositions for anybody that that would um well I mean
maybe would they help our case? Who knows? We haven't deposed
them yet. The depositions of plaintiff and defendant have not
been rescheduled despite plaintiff's good faith's effort to do
so. So, the thing that scares me about this um
um about trying to move back the dates here is that this argument
is decently strong and generally like we're going to fight the
motion, but like generally speaking, you have to depose the parties
to the case. So, because the judge hasn't ruled on our protective
order and because neither party, so me nor Pixie have been deposed
yet, I feel like there's I feel like the judge will extend the
discovery. I guess I'm hoping maybe it'll only be a month instead
of this is just how it's going. Yeah, this is this is where we're
at at this point. Listen, Laura is completely uninvolved in in
the case, but also she is dodging subpoenas and all of our requests
for evidence from her. Come on, give me the evidence. Give me
the evidence.
Okay. Uh, what should I do? I should chill right now. Guys, if
you like the content, go ahead, follow on every platform. Follow
on Twitter. Follow on Twitch. twitch.tv/jsdlk
with an underscore at the end. Same with Twitter. Okay. Uh, join
the Patreon.
Join the Discord. discord.gg/j GG/JS. Okay. Join the community.
You could be one of the people that Destiny goes after and he
tries to dox. Okay. Since he's going to, I guess, just dox indiscriminately
from this community, even people he was friends with from before.
Very cool. Very neat. All right.
And if you really like the content, you can go ahead, you can
sub, you can donate. All right. Donating subs on kicks. Best
way to do it. It's 955 split goes directly into my bank account.
You want to add more time to the stream, you can do so. chatter.
I believe we are one sub away from another hour on the stream
right now. Um, I'm probably going to do the two $30 ones. Okay,
so we could add another hour already. That would make us We're
five subs away from another hour. Okay, we already got one hour.
Five subs from another hour. Okay, and what else? There's also
the Streamlabs link, the Kickbot link. Okay, you guys know all
the ways to donate. You want to donate, make the stream go longer,
go ahead, hit the sub button, donate, donate, donate. Sub with
your Twitch primers, do whatever you can. There's the Patreon.
That's that's the whole shell. I'm not going to do the whole
thing. Okay,
let's go. Let's go. >> Two months. I don't know. Um, but
like we can't we haven't done anything. So, is that allowed?
If it is, why don't you do it, too? Why don't I do what? There's
nothing for me to do. I don't have anything to hide. Like, I
don't like I don't need to do anything like that. I don't need
to. And also, technically, all the depositions they've done have
just been incredibly helpful to me. Their deposition of Rose,
which they thought was going to be this slam dunk crazy thing,
ended up biting them in the ass hardcore. Halfway through that
[__] deposition, they realized they were completely
and totally.
I I don't know if it actually hurts their case at all.
I don't know.
>> Oh, hold on one second.
>> Uh, Spruce Willis, thank you for the gifted sub. I don't
know if it actually hurts their case at all, but it absolutely
makes him look worse. Like the deposition, the things they've
put out from the deposition,
it makes him look horrible. How, dude? Yes, it did come out that
this minor did view my then yes, I did solicit material from
this minor through her child sex trafficker, but and then I retained
that that child abuse material after the child trafficker themselves
informed me that she was underage. Yes, I did all these things,
but have you thought about Lauren de Laguna's ellipses? Dot dot
dot means Lauren de Lagona and I am innocent of all charges.
And DJ just be like, "Yes, yes,
yes.
We knew it. We knew you were innocent all destiny." Yes. Yes.
Let's go. No, I don't I don't have anything to hide on this.
Like all my is bleak to the public, is out in the open is whatever.
Anyway, like the only people who to hide right now are Lauren,
who is apparently stalking, harassing me publicly when I visit
other states. And then Pixie who likes to just close her eyes
like they're and pretend that none of this is even happening
while she, you know, travels around to Miami and hangs OUT WITH
>> SHE'S FROLICKING. THIS STUPID [__] IS FROLICKING.
She's frolicking.
How dare she frolic. She ruined my life and she's frolicking.
>> Her fake wife and post these videos on TikTok or whatever.
Um, and then, you know, does her seven years of law school in
Illinois or however the long it's going to take her to get her
fourth degree. The deposition of nonparty witness Molina Uren
has not yet been scheduled. I don't even know what they could
possibly hope. Oh, the whole lie he just did about Lauren de
Laguna there, I guess, is um
I'm guessing that's because he's worried about what is on her
video. Exactly. Right. Like she's got a video of him and he really
wants her to post it, so he keeps like pressuring her to post
it. I don't know what's on that video, but he's like he was like
freaking out. He's like, "I'll pay you $100,000 to post that
video.
I don't remember. Or maybe it was like if it says that he walked
up to her. I can't remember. But it uh he definitely was like
losing it about the video. I do think he's just like a little
worried about what's said in it or what's on it that she might
have been recording first and if he was saying something he she
doesn't like then or if he was saying something that could hurt
him in some way. I don't know. >> Hope to talk to her about.
But okay.
Furthermore, while plaintiff diligently sought and participated
in a discovery since the issuance of the protective order, defendants
production of documents has been demonstrably deficient and tardy.
Plaintiff engaged in a meet and confer with defense council which
resulted in supplemental production of documents. >> Oh,
hello. >> Rean Rubin donated $3 fourth degree. Bro should
worry about his first degree. >> The stupid educated
>> including the most recent production on November 25th,
but plaintiff contents that the production is still deficient
and thus anticipates filing a motion to compel. Yeah, we'll see.
Um, the last stuff, oh, actually, I should say the last stuff
that they tried to ask for was I think they were saying like,
"We need all your recent conversations with like food shops and
Zip Zip" or whatever. And it's like, "Excuse me. Uh, I'm sorry,
you stupid. You don't get to just like mine all my random personal
conversations cuz you're fuck."
So, again, uh, he clearly read the transcript directly to Food
Chops. He clearly on Food Chops's stream while talking to her
in a Discord said, "Check this out. Check this out." Was sending
her like personal screenshots of things, right? So, so that's
random and unrelated, but him with no pretense for going after
Lauren de Laguda is saying that's totally justified. I need Lauren
de all of Lauren de Laguda's messages.
Okay. Uh, what do you think the percentage chance is that this
goes to court as of what we know now? Um,
I think it's going to go to mediation. I think there's a way
higher. So, the mediation thing doesn't necessarily mean anything.
The judge probably is telling them to go to mediation, right,
before they go to trial, right? The trial date is in 6 months,
5 months now. I'm guessing the judge was like, "Hey, you guys
need to go to mediation if you haven't made any progress here
at all." Right?
And I think there's actually a higher chance than not that it
will go to mediation and it will just get settled cuz realistically,
this going to trial is probably extremely threat financially
threatening to both of them. And realistically, this has not
really helped either of them.
I think the only thing that could get in the way of it is Destiny's
ego. I think probably everybody else is usually willing. Most
people are willing to look at their lives a lot of the time and
go, "Hey, I just want to go live my life now." Right? Pixie is
trying to frolic. Destiny is sitting here like seething. I don't
know. The thing is, I don't think Pixie will like or maybe I
I don't think she'd do like the things he demanded before. So,
if they do settle, I'm guessing it'll be in some fairly neutral
way without admissions of of guilt. And I'm guessing that he's
going to try to present that as a win, even though he said he
would never settle. Pixie is the most disgusting person ever,
right? Um it would be better for both parties if they settle,
but I think um I think Pixie's also not talked about a lot of
stuff publicly because she wants to talk about it in court, right?
Uh any settlement would have to involve some clauses against
future retaliation, otherwise what's the point? Um yeah.
Yeah,
I think when he sees when he like understands the price tag for
going to actual court over this, it's I don't I just could see
things changing, man. Destiny is risking mass massive criminal
exposure if Pixie gets a Discord subpoena and this goes to trial.
His logs are probably unhinged. I don't think so. Um I mean,
it's it's America. The logs are free speech.
Um yeah, I just don't think so. I will say
he's probably like probably he did. Sorry, I do know that he
did the whole like um Cardi violation. He's done that a lot.
But that's a civil action. It's not a crime,
right? That's not a crime. It's not criminal. If you just mean
like he probably sent a lot of people's around without their
consent, then yes, he did. He obviously did. >> Yeah. Not
the logs with a >> and you're some loser with their life
but read through my Discord logs. Like eat [__] kick
rocks. Like get the [__] out of here. It's so stupid.
The the last three and there were like three or four rand. So,
like there's actually reasons to believe that he sent things
that are improper to food shops. There's he's he has colluded
directly with food shops about messaging online about the case
and that would be relevant to the case itself, right? Like obviously
obviously I don't even know what else to say. Obviously, that's
the case.
So, I don't understand how he make that argument, but he he makes
the argument that Lauren is more involved somehow. Random Discord
people like we need all your reason. Shut the [__]
the out of here. give me a single conversation that's actually
responsive to what we've asked for. And
but plenty require adequate time to investigate her forensic
experts findings of potential spoliation and tampering of evidence
by a defendant. How much more time do you need to sit there and
read some guy who's techiterate to to who who already who filed
a reply to to retract two paragraphs of his quote unquote expert
witness testimony like the day after he filed it. Give me a break.
which plaintiff could not have anticipated. In view of the incomplete
discovery and the looming discovery cutoff date, plaintiff's
council proposed that the parties file a joint motion to extend
the deadlines and suggested dates for the Okay, hold on. Hold
on, guys. We're going to go to kick for the rest of the stream.
Okay, head over to kick. We'll see you there in a little bit.
All right, head over to kick right now.
We'll see you there in just a minute. Okay, we'll see you. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. Got off the multireaming thingoop and we stop on Twitch.
Okay, here we go. We're good to go. We're going to continue.
There's I think there's still some more stuff here. Hold on.
Let me let me just make sure in these time stamps. >> Depositions
of plaintiff and defendant during the same week in early January.
Oh, so now you can schedule it in the same week. Oh, I thought
before that was impossible. But if it's going to be past the
December deadline. Oh, now all of a sudden you're willing to
do it. Good one. Good one. >> I think the argument was
undue burden.
>> See exhibit V or exhibit B. Defendants refusal to agree
to a reasonable modification of certain deadlines, smacks of
bad faith and gamesmanship and an ulterior motive to prevent
the defendant's deposition from taking place. Even the moderate
request moderate request for 60-day continuance plaintiff proposed
would make it difficult to allow the parties to re >> Okay,
I'm going to I'm going to head over to the um what the this will
be the >> you file.
>> This is him covering like Pixie stuff. Okay, the actual
Pixie filings
>> for sanctions against me. I file for sanctions against
>> I just think like I think pretty obviously I'm just
gonna ask again and since I think Destiny was watching earlier
people were saying if he's watching now I would just I would
love for some
evidence of the things he just said about Lauren and Pixie like
you know for a fact 100% they're deleting evidence you know for
a fact they're 100% collud like what evidence do you have of
this? I would just love to know what evidence there is of this
in general.
Like what? What reason do you even have to believe this other
than you're just like schizosphere tapping, right? Like are you
just are you just making this up? I would love to know you
Bonnell's rule 11 motion. Wait, what is this? This is a response
in opposition defendants motion. Oh, this is their response and
then the next one is the whatever. Yeah, Ronaldo's rule of in
motion constitutes a textbook example of a frivolous sanctions
motion brought for the sole purpose of harassing an intimidating
plaintiff in a withdrawing
testing the factual strength or legal sufficiency of plaintiff's
claims. Um, so again, I understand I don't know if it's a where
they normally practice law. Maybe Carlos and Joan don't read
English and so they're using a translation. Maybe Pixie's bored
and she's playwriting a lot of these motions or
Latinos can't speak English. Puerto Ricans can't speak English.
You love to see it. Let's go. WDGG getting on the anti-immigration
pill. Let's do it. >> Has in between the 200 clients she's
get Pixie's wife deported by ICE and her Puerto Rican lawyers.
Okay. These these non-American non-English-speaking [__]
Let's go. >> Has um in her Florida law firm that existed
as of two months ago. Uh maybe she's doing all the writing. But
the Can we get Can we get an Adam Mocka review of this stream?
I does Adam Mockler's stream. Can we get an Adam Mockler review
of Destiny calling ICE on the wife of the person he's being sued
by for for divulging their information without their consent?
For sending videos of them without their consent. We get the
Adam Mach review in this one. Rose could have been a one-year-old
and it would have no bearing on plaintiff's case. This case has
nothing to do with who received the status of a person who received
has nothing to do with any of that. That's not what's at at play
here. So, I don't know why shoving random things in a footnote
to try to harass me is testing the factual strength or legal
sufficiency of plaintiff's claims. Um, if either of you are if
you guys are listening because apparently you listen on my streams,
I can email you the statutes if if you need like to walk through
the element one by one by one by one. There is no age thing listed
out in any of these statutes. So, I'm not sure where you're getting
these things. I know like to make up quotes and parts of the
laws, but
okay. What again under this same thing? Why is Lauren de Laguna
relevant to this?
Dude, what? Jesus Christ. Such a tactical rule 11 motion is itself
subject to rule 11 sanctions under well settled 11th circuit
president. The strategic yet frivolous nature of Bunnel's motion
is substantiated by several factors. First, Bunnel declined to
raise his objections and his reply to the fraction of the response
to the motion to dismiss he now attacks.
Second, Bunnel's protestations are bi when did that wait, what
what was the date of that? Had we done the deposition yet? We
might not have known. The reply is de 149 October 10th. Oh, that's
another issue too, you guys. So, like October 10th um so we had
on the 23rd. Hold on, hold on, hold on. Sorry. I need to do a
paint for this.
>> we get chat back on screen. Yeah, sure. I'll throw a
chat up. I'll throw a chat >> Oh, we used to make these
in math class in first grade. I think these are called like number
lines. So, 10 is here. Okay, so you go like 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 21 22 23. Okay, time goes in one direction. How the
are we going to say something here on the 10th to some piece
of information we discovered on the 23rd? Do you see how this
number here is way after this number here? Did you say that comes
way after unless you have
we done the deposition yet? We might not have known.
>> Oh, was it was it like uh judged or did he not have
time? Maybe he just didn't have time cuz I think should you not
be able to amend a response or something before it's judged?
Like right now, couldn't you actually file like an amendment
to that? Like, hey, we we've got these new facts and we want
to dispute there. Like isn't that
so like you could say they said decline to, but I think this
is sort of hinting at the more appropriate venue would be in
opposition to that motion.
I'm guessing that motion hasn't been ruled on, right? The reply
is de 149 October 10th. Oh, that's another issue too, you guys.
So like October 10th. Um, so we had on the 23rd. Hold on, hold
on, hold on. Sorry. I need to do a paint.
>> I guess I could just look it up. Hold on one second.
Where is the go here? Let's check this out. Okay, so we go here.
Oh, we have to go back. Ah, god damn it. Hold on. Hold on. October
10th. This is 149. Uh, reply and supportive of motion
defendants. Uh, so this is the motion to dismiss. Yeah, you could
just update your motion to dismiss, right? You should you could
just file an amendment to one of these motions and then they
go like, "Oh, well, new facts came out thanks to discovery, so
you could go and amend that in,
right?" And that's what they're saying is that's like the more
appropriate place to do it. Um I think you'd have to file a motion
for like leave to amend something that was filed a long time
ago. But I think it's like probably be fine. Oh no. Anyway,
this is the one, right? Yeah, this is the one. Let's continue.
B Protestations are belied by the evidence aduced to date and
the fact himself referred to the exchanges described in this
beautiful footnote in the identical manner which plaintiff it.
Yeah, but more information came out. We have more more information
because you morons thought that you could do a big owner awesome
deposition that ended up exploding in your face.
Third final objections are patently premature. By way of example,
as of the Why? Hold on. Wait, why why did I don't
why he thinks this blew up in their face.
I Yeah, hold on. This is um this is what you call the This is
him just like setting a narrative. It's him just telling them
what reality is, right? when reality is the opposite. This is
him unironically going, "Yes, I He is He's just doing this. He's
just doing this." [laughter]
Dude, we pro We proved It wasn't this. It was this. And this
is fine. This is fine. This is totally fine. Okay. This is fine.
This is good. This is not fine. This is not good. Do this. Don't
do this. Wow. Very cool. Time of World Ser
by the way. Also, when I do pull this up, hold on. Somebody say
it's covered by chat a little bit. Sure. That's uh that's Rose
over there. Okay. When I do pull this up, the funny thing is
is they actually do argue that this
is they before they were arguing that this isn't bad cuz Desty
didn't know that Desi couldn't confirm that she was a minor,
Doesn't Leave alone the fact that he apparently asked for some
verification. Didn't get it. That he was on a non-ageverified
platform. Leave alone all those facts. But apparently this wasn't
bad because he didn't think she was a minor. So nothing really
changes here because he still doesn't think she's a minor. This
doesn't this doesn't tangibly change anything actually. There's
nothing changed here, right?
What what changes if if your argument was he didn't know she
was a minor so all of this is fine. Which by the way I talk about
him retaining this after learning she was a minor. That's why
that's my problem, right? cuz you could easily argue that oh
well he solicited this material under the oposes of her being
like an adult and then he I don't know then he retained it all
when he found out she was a kid but it's either way so nothing
actually changed for DG years that's they they act like Destiny's
like oh this is like the most cataclysmic change but it's not
it's literally not just not using MS pain out of pure spite um
no Excalibur is way
deposition including to testify about the events in question.
At most, Bono might opt to raise his objections in any motion
for summary judgement or motion for lamine at the appropriate
juncture or he could have moved to strike. Fourth
um back arguing rather that immaterial will be because when you're
a lawyer you make multiple arguments at the same time, right?
That's why you have five different arguments here and not just
one because you always make every argument you can. Right.
But you so then you made that you made that argument too. It
seems he did not include this argument about Rose's age. Well,
you make all of your arguments. Yeah, that's what we're saying.
Actually, you just said exactly what we said. You make all of
your arguments. One of the arguments you made was not that she
was not underage.
Wait, Destiny, you could just clarify now and say she was not
underage. Destiny, you could just say right now that she was
not underage. Hello, Destiny. Mr. Destiny, you could just say
it right now and you'd actually get the same clearance in the
post court of public opinion. Well, sorry. We'd we'd probably
just look at reality and say you're lying. But do you want to
put a lie down on the record? You're trying to use this to dance,
but just put the lie on the record. He's trying to say no, she
wasn't a minor at all. And he just said something,
right? Indeed, Bon was apparently concerned enough about Rose
having been minor at the time that he raised the issue at her
deposition.
In fact, Bon fails to disclose in his world of emotion. What
does this have to do with anything? Exhibit A, the declaration,
blah blah bl himself. Dude, as he sits here on his stream going,
"This stupid is like lying and this deposition was a total win
for me." Oh no, facts from the deposition. What does this have
to do with anything? What does this have to do with anything?
He's literally trying to farm wins from the deposition, right?
He's saying the deposition was a total win from him and then
they file like facts from THAT DEPOSITION. NO. WHAT ARE YOU DO?
WHY WOULD YOU FILE RESPONSIVE FACTS TO MY ALLEGATIONS? Why would
you say that my allegations are false and put things on the record?
Why would you do that? So irrelevant. generally refers to exchanges
of materials between violent rows in the same manner plaintiff
did in the footnote and tellingly raised no such objection to
the footnote therein. Yeah, because we didn't have the information
at the time. Why am I even reading this? I'm just kidding. It's
just here. This just to troll me. >> So inconvenient.
>> It is patently [snorts] clear that Vinal's argument
boils down to an objection to the relevance of Rose's age at
the time. But he and he bases this objection on representations
to this quote which are however anything but undisputed.
Specifically, Vinyl posits that the fact that Rose's manner is
irrelevant because one, Rose's then boyfriend solo was catfishing.
Two, Rose was not directly operating the social media account
through which the materials were exchanged any of the accounts
by the way. and three rose did not see any plaintiff material
materials on D183 despite the fact that it is patently improper
to force plaintiff to litigate these highly disputed factual
issues at this stage of the case for the reason set forth in
sections two and three and for a plaint of addresses why balance
contentions are then why are you putting them in footnotes I
we should go hold on did somebody link me the footnote could
can someone link me the document that the footnote is in and
I'll just I'll just go read the foot footnote and see what it's
like responding to and see if it's like at all relevant I think
at the time I wanted to say like it seemed like just a shot like
they just wanted put that in there to [__] with him.
I unfortunately I just kind of understand why.
I I do. >> Why would you put something like >> And
now But now unfortunately because you've had to spur about the
footnote, right? They get to correct your your your
lies about the footnote. So now it's all going on the record.
This is just another just like literally jumping off of a diving
board directly onto a rake that smashes him in the face. I don't
understand. I don't get it. >> There's no footnote.
>> Oh, it's relevant because she stated he stated she was
19 and also they stated that. Oh. Oh, no way. Really?
Okay. >> no, for example, that Rose also testify that solar
shared with her materials when sent to Rose over the imposttor
account. C, exhibit A. Um, Rosemary that she was shown a handful
of videos of Destiny sent via the imposter account. Rose also
testified that Solo shared with her the Discord messages exchanged
with Bunell. I'm not sending these though. I'm not the one sending
these. Your stupid didn't name Solo as a party to the case. You're
not suing him. You're suing me. I'm not the one sending these
things to that other person. Yeah, she's not arguing that. She's
arguing that it was an exchange through an
That's that's what the argument is right now, right?
Trying to say that it was shared through you. you were having
this right through this intermediary
exchanging the exchange of materials
that yeah again you could like kind of shuck a jive on uh on
like whether or not Rose's testimony is valid to the case if
she didn't see any of the materials but it sounds like she did
see materials from him like she did have that stuff forwarded
on and Destiny just going like oh well um you can't say I the
dispute is whether or not they exchanged and that's not really
relevant to the case right like nitpicking over that is not relevant
to the case. Like they're filing a motion saying it's irrelevant
when So Desi says something, he alleges something and then somebody
else comes in and go the the opposition goes, "You're lying.
Actually, here's what it is." And he goes, "That that correction
is totally irrelevant to the case." So he lies, they correct
the lie, and he goes, "That's totally irrelevant to the case."
It's very interesting. And that she knew that the explicit images
and videos um that she took of herself would be provided to Banell.
Rose further testified that she does not know the plaintiff.
Um, this is important because if Rose is hand the plaintiff,
she could not know one way or another whether one of the handful
of videos that Destiny sent depicted plaintiff
because you cuz stuff has come out afterwards because stuff was
leaked online. I'm getting one guide. I'm not getting one guide.
Based on these facts, the question whether Rose ever saw PL materials
is anything but undisputed. Even if she So Pixie So Pixie sent
Holy Pixie sent to a child, by the way. Um, is that what we're
saying now? Is this No, obviously not. I mean, technically Pixie
wasn't involved in the exchange because she didn't get anything
back, right? She sent it to you. That's it got sent along. Like,
obviously, you're not on the hook for sending those videos. Well,
hold on.
Actually, it's way different. No, no, no. Hold on. It's way different.
If you were posing as the Hold on, hold on. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. He got me off. He He said something. So, I lost my
mind for a second. Hold on, hold on. Were you posing as a child,
Destiny? Were you posing as somebody who was factually underage?
Were you using the picture of somebody who's factually underage
and nude images of that person to catfish pixie into talking
to you or
is that what was happening or
cuz that's what happened here, right? Dude, >> based on
these facts, the question whether Rose ever stops playing materials
is anything but undisputed. Even if she So,
>> dude, I was totally catfished by somebody pretending
to be a minor. Wait, what? How did they get you by pretending
to Wait, how did they get you by pretending to be a minor? What?
So Pixie sent Holy That's not totally accurate. It's satire.
It's not totally accurate to a trial. Is that what we're saying
now? Is this the Is this the transitive property of bad legal
arguments? Damn, that's
I would say there is something here legally that like, oh, can
we accept Rose's like testimony if she didn't get sent anything
at all right now? She got sent videos of him. This is all bad
news for him in terms of the like court of public opinion. like
factual things about him that make him look really weird, right?
That like cement facts of reality that make him look horrible.
So that's why he's getting mad because these are facts of the
case that might end up getting deemed irrelevant, but they're
being established in reality for everybody else to use against
him in the future. That's what he's upset about, right? He doesn't
like that personal things about him, like true facts are being
released to the public in a way that can be used against him
in the future. He's not saying they're lies. They're not lies.
That this occurred. Yes. He's saying that well technically technically
the testimony from this person in the case is irrelevant because
I don't think like this happened with regards to the Pixie video.
Oh, sorry. Hold on. How far do I have to go back to get rid?
No, I don't want that. Never mind. I don't think this happened
with regards to the Pixie video. That's like that's what he's
saying, right? So,
I I totally get that from a legal case perspective, but from
like a totally deranged Gooner perspective, it's a little weird.
Okay.
I think the biggest revelation we've seen from all of this is
him just saying, "Yeah, I could easily find Silbo." Um, I could
easily find Solo, but I'm going to let this international trafficker,
as I call him, go because Pixie's mean.
That's the That has been to me the highlight of this so far.
I'm not sure why he puts that on the record. Very strange. I
can't believe she did that.
gross. Rule 11 sanctions against Banel are warranted for exhibiting
a deliberate indifference to obvious facts.
Furthermore, Ros's testimony also reveals that because A, she
was aware of Banel being catfished through the imposter account
and that explicit material of her would be shared with Banel.
Banell was making requests for explicit material and that C materials
were being shared in this manner and then at times shown to her,
she was at least indirectly communicating with Bonell
base argument. True. This person
Wait, that is Wait, is he going to contend with that? that like
basically she just didn't want the she didn't want the tedium
of having to like sift through the disgusting,
right? She's like, "No, I'm good. I'm good. You want to you want
to get this guy on the hook? Okay, whatever. But I'm not going
to talk to him directly." Right.
Oh, you just want you just want some Oh, here you go. Here's
You can send him. Oh, he's requesting like feet pics. Okay, I'll
send him some fee pics then.
like like you were soliciting
through a child trafficker
child. That is what was happening in in actuality. Yes, we all
understand. We all understand that. Not to say nothing of his
intent or whether he knew the age like what he thought about
the age. It's just pointless to mind read it. But he was in fact
soliciting child from a child sex trafficker.
Didn't do his due diligence in confirming ages. Didn't do his
due diligence anywhere.
Right. by the way, who told me that they were 18 or 19 years
old. This person who I no no no claims whatsoever about this
person being a minor ever. Number one. Number two, I'm not even
talking to this [__] You were told directly that
she was a minor after you continue to retain the child in November
of 2024.
2024.
Yeah. In November of 2024, you continued to retain that child.
You told Billy Mack as much. You said you said he was lying.
You said everybody was lying. It has now come out via this these
these filings that you were sent child abuse materials. You did
in fact have child abuse materials person. I'm talking to a person
operating the account catfishing. Okay. But based we're basically
we're we're basically we're basically besties is what my good
friend Carlos here is trying to say. Thank you. Your honor.
Does does nobody in the chat understand at all that he solicited
like custommade bespoke child
from a child sex trafficker
and that like there is some weight to that regardless of there
is some weight to that regardless of his uh what he understood
at the time right especially if there's proof somewhere
that he
kind of suspected that she might be young that he was like trying
to check her age that he didn't do his due diligence at all thus
the footnote stating that Bono was exchanging material with the
minor is not incorrect so so I guess Pixie was too then the fact
that Solo acted as a go-between a
The guy who was trafficking her is a go between I'm just again
we we go between
we go between the performative exasperation at them talking about
the relationship between Rose and this guy, right? And then hey
Destiny, you have like information on this guy, right? Yeah,
but I'm like way too mentally to do anything about it. Yeah,
but I'm way too mentally to do anything about it. Like I How
can you both sides this? How can you be too much of a victim
to do the bare minimum to go and find this guy's information
and make sure he doesn't get away with actually actual child
trafficking, right? Why can't you do that? I don't I just don't
understand how you could play both sides of this is [__]
crazy. >> That's okay. Go between
based
doesn't alter this assertion. Well, I mean it kind of does, but
okay. The fact remains that Beno requested explicit material.
How? How? How?
You think you're talking to this person. This person knows they're
talking. They're sending stuff back to this person. From your
perspective, you are exchanging material with this person, right?
This is what you think.
And you're like, "Oh, somebody else could see this along the
way as they pass things along. That changes everything." What
does it change? What
again like uh in terms of like the actions? What What has changed?
What changes in terms of it being an exchange? He's just performatively
exasperated. He's just performatively exasperated.
I have no idea.
And I'm exasperated in actuality that this guy that it's come
out that this guy is protecting the actual child sex trafficker.
It's not the first time Destiny has collabed with a child sex
Have a minor and that the minor provided it for him and he received
it and viewed it. I no indication that this person was underage
at the time. I'm not requesting anything directly from this person.
I'm not even sure. I should go through if they offered this all
or if I was requesting anything.
I believe they
is that not said
I have to go back and check. I don't even know if I requested
anything. This person was forthcoming a whole bunch of [__]
But this
definitely asked him to to plug up with you though, right? >> Person
apparently was her creepy weirdo adult boyfriend from the UK
who was running the account. But okay. Oh, he just claimed Solo
was an adult. Now, I thought that was one thing he could hide
behind, that maybe Solo was like a minor as well, and that he
didn't want to dox this person who was like young or he he was
scared of that. Okay. But now he's lost that one, too. So, he
said that they're an adult. Why is he protecting this child sex
trafficker? He's the only person with the information. And while
Rose repeatedly testified that she did not message directly with
Bonell, she also testified that she did not recall whether she
ever spoke to him via other means. I honestly don't remember
if I ever called Bonell. Moreover, bon produced in this case
his communication with an individual with a screen named straight
rate which included messages on November 29th in which he states
that he had decent link phone calls with Rose multiple times
by both of our personal things. Never had a problem issue fight
over literally anything else. I thought I had at the time it's
possible that there was another person I was chatting with on
the phone instead. I know that this Rose person offered to call
me or we talked about calling. Um although at this point apparently
Solo literally could have just had her call me and we we would
have talked that way. But none of this is material to any of
this stuff. Um, I think after I said this when Pixie filed her
court case, I'm pretty sure I went back and I checked the logs
that I had. By the way, that Pixie has as well because unlike
her, I actually produce my discovery information. There are no
calls in our Discord history and I have no calls on my phone
logs without calling any phone numbers from or anything else.
So, um, do you think it was a woman or someone using a voice
changer? No. If I would have called her, it would have been around
the time when all the crazy launch was happening. But there was
again just really quick, Destiny said to multiple people that
he really trusted the person, right? That he known for 10 days
when he sent the video. That's That's what he's trying to do,
right? Um
he's saying he didn't remember. He is saying he was really emotionally
distraught when he told Pixie that he talked to this person a
lot and so he just he just like misremembered that he was talking
to somebody else. Um I don't I don't think he ever updated them.
I don't think he ever like talked to them further about it. He
was clearly just trying to dodge accountability. He wanted them
to think that like, oh, there's no reason to expect that this
could have gone anywhere, right? But there was every reason to
expect that it would have gone anywhere or gone somewhere, right?
Like you knew this person for 10 days and you're sending your
friends to them. That's what was happening.
There's every reason to suspect that could get leaked. Come on,
man. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Crazy Lauren. He
is downplaying his infidelity. I mean, yeah. I mean, he's the
crazier thing is that he sent Molina's like psychology do like
the document for Molina's therapist that he sent that to like
so many people like all of these incredibly personal things about
them and their relationship, right? You prepare a total like
totally transparent document about your issues with for a therapist
and Destiny sends it to multiple women that
that's crazy, right? Like that's more from the whole Lauren thing,
his whole meltdown there. That's one of the bigger ones. Okay,
that's rough. another person I was talking to too. So, my guess
is I was just talking to this person, but um I was texting the
this solo person, I guess, a lot as well. But >> I don't
even know what the story. Why would I lie? >> This this
solo guy is a sick puppy a little bit. Okay. Jesus Christ, dude.
That's that's some crazy [__] to put.
Man, those logs are disgusting. Those logs take on an entirely
different meaning now. GH
says there are no logs of the calls, but you can't delete a call
on log on Discord, so it won't show up on the Redact database.
based Discord log he showed. Um,
no. No, they still output Discord logs or they still output calls.
Um, I would assume redact doesn't like need to delete something
to save it
that when you like do a save in redact. I assume it like archives
the stuff first and then it just deletes. I don't think it like
needs to delete to show. And I have I have Discord logs of my
own that show calls that show call logs, call length because
you can't delete them. So, I don't know. Why would I lie about
this? Unless the unless the Oh, well, I guess the logistical
Discord theory is that I contacted Rose ahead of time and then
me and her um set up a whole devious plot to with Pixie, I guess.
Oh, I don't think that. I I definitely don't think that. Um I
don't know why he's saying my Discord thinks that. Discord's
full of like a lot of people who think different things. Is there
somebody in the Discord who is saying this in a serious way?
I think like you got to you got to understand it's a Discord.
People get bored and they just go like, "Oh, wouldn't this be
crazy?"
I like even if somebody typed that out, I feel like I do that
sometimes. I just like write crazy like, "Oh, wouldn't it be
crazy if this happened?" But it's not saying it, you know, it's
not saying you believe it.
What?
is the loose rumor about Anessy and Rose? Oh, yeah. But that
was just like,
"Oh, yeah, that happened or whatever." And I I just laughed about
it because I was like, "Oh, this seems like totally coincident."
Yeah, I I said it was a total coincidence. But yeah, the idea
that um Aerodite could go and do that or something on Destiny's
behalf. That was probably crazy. I think I think
I don't know. Um but yeah, it wouldn't be like a whole plot to
with Rose. It would be like, "Hey, just so you know, some people
are going to come try to talk to you, but you have to dodge it
or something like that." Wouldn't be to [__] with
Pixie. Couldn't have been to Pixie, actually, according to Destiny,
cuz Rose's testimony is totally irrelevant to the case. She wasn't
the person he was talking to, right? As such, Bonn's claim that
he never communicated with Rose, including when she was a minor,
is misleading and belied by the record. How unbelievably inappropriate
in in in a back and forth in in a civil suit that has nothing
to do with child or anything to try to be litigating this in
these. They're just correcting you, bro. That's why it was really
weird for you to go on the record and say like, "Oh, it's so
up that they did this, that they said she was 19. It's so up
that they said she was 19
or sorry, that they said she was 17. Sorry, 17. He said she was
19. They said they corrected said she was 17. He just he gets
corrected on the things his lawyers say. They get corrected and
he's like, "It's so INSANE FOR THEM TO SAY THIS. JUST LET ME
LIE. Just let me lie." [__] replies and these rule
11 sanctions. Like Jesus Christ. Like these are big claims. Like
if you want to have like a formal actual case relating to this,
well then let's do that. But the fact that I have to litigate
whether or not I'm a in replies to to court motions on a totally
unrelated
I mean realistically outside of the memes. Okay, there's two
things actual dictionary definition.
No. Okay, probably not. Probably something like a heapile, something
like that. Okay. But in terms of, you know, what people on the
internet will call someone who after being told the they've received
from a young person is in fact child and then they choose to
retain that child, we're probably all going to call that person
a and like be okay with it even though it's like not technically
dictionarily correct. You know what I'm saying? Like people on
the internet, they be using the word a lot. You know,
I think probably somebody who holds on to child after being informed
that they're a child as you probably call that. I don't know.
I don't know it matter like Jesus.
>> The evidence shows was [laughter] also victimized by
blood altering.
>> The Kiwi Farms arguments copy pasting all of it. >> I
I don't think they do. They make that argument on Kiwi Farms.
I made that
immediately when he did that. What? I he he just says like my
the things I say that I come up with and then tweet or put into
the ether. He just says their Kiwi Farms arguments as if that's
a response in any way. It's not, by the way, it's just not. >> And
that despite suspecting that Rose was a minor, I never suspected
Rose was a minor ever. Why the would I post anything about this
per They know this. I don't know why I'm shouting.
>> No, no, no, no. >> They know this is all [__]
>> No, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. They're saying
that you could have sus you probably suspected or you had reason
to suspect that she could be a minor after you were informed
she was a minor. And like I think it's pretty low chance.
But I remember when I dude
it was like low chance but he was concerned about it. Yes, he
was concerned about it. Absolutely. Yes. Yes. Exactly. I was
like trying to reassure this guy. I don't think she's a minor.
But like I I I need to stress that when I said I don't think
she's a minor. That was not me going. Totally. Keep that child,
bro. You're good. You're good. You're Gucci. She's definitely
not a minor. Keep that child. Keep that, bro. Keep that dog.
You good. You good. No, that wasn't
Despite suspecting there was was a minor. Um, he tried to send
a group of guys to find her because he wanted to talk to her.
Yeah, because my impression at the time was either she was directly
involved in le
Okay, hold on. Oh, so he's admitting to this Discord group chat
again,
Okay. The cops got to be on this, right? The cops have to be
there has to be some child protective thing happening somewhere
that's looking into this [__] right? That's Come
on, man. He's like, "Yeah, I did after after this guy told me
she was a minor, I started a Discord group and I sent all the
to this Discord GROUP CHAT, BRO. COME ON. THERE'S GOT TO be sub.
Come on.
That's crazy.